there was a bit of strange news coming
out of the doj in the last two days
which is that Ray Epps
is going to be charged Ray Epps is this
strange figure from January 6th Ray EP
sorry
January 6th the worst day in the history
of America the worst cool day time so
rayaps is this odd figure from January 6
because he is the most prominent guy
that we have on camera we have on audio
multiple times
urging people to break into the capital
on January 6th he was so officious in
his calls for the mob to get unruly and
to aggress on Capitol Hill that a group
of people around him when he was calling
for this said he was a Fed said wait a
second you're just trying to egg us on
you're a Fed fed fed and we're chanting
it all around him but he kept it up and
he kept chanting for people to go into
the into the capital he was on the FBI's
website he's still he still appears in
an FBI tweet Most Wanted people from
January 6th
but he wasn't charged with a crime he
wasn't arrested he's like the only guy
from January 6 that that was not
arrested or charged for the crime so a
lot of people have suggested that he's a
fed the the suggestion that he was a Fed
was then bolstered by the liberal media
defending this guy don't forget the
liberal media had called John number six
the worst day ever and it was the almost
the end of the Republic and it was a
coup d'etat
and yet they're defending the most
prominent instigator of January 6th that
didn't make a lot of sense glowing
Profiles In The New York Times a
constant defense of him now rayap saying
he's going to sue Fox News for
defamation
probably in the hopes that fox will just
settle out of court and now the doj
comes out and says Ray Epps is going to
be charged so the timing of this is
convenient
at the same time that that rayapse is
bringing a lawsuit against Fox News to
try to have a Shakedown and get some
money and maybe further tarnish Tucker
Carlson's reputation in the liberal
media
the doj is saying okay well we're we are
finally going to arrest him
but that doesn't answer anything
why did it take two and a half years why
did the doj round up every Midwestern
granny who had the audacity to take a
photograph in the capital rotunda on
January 6th they rounded them all up
within about a week they threw a lot of
them into prison they throw a lot of
them into solitary confinement
yet this guy the most prominent
instigator of the whole thing whose
location we've all known because he said
these glowing magazine and newspaper
profiles
the doj Waits two and a half years what
is this about I think they're hoping
that this puts to rest the conspiracy
theory that Ray Epps has some
relationship with the federal government
to me this just adds fuel to the fire
that this seems even more bizarre than
had they not charged him in the first
place doesn't explain a damn thing seems
a little bit like smoke in mirrors now
there is some good news coming out of
the doj and it actually relates directly
to me we'll get to that in just one
second first though when you want to
talk to all of your friends about the
threats and the joys and the the news
that's going on in this country
you got to check out pure talk right now
go to puretalk.com you know a company is
looking out for you when they actually
upgrade your service and don't even
charge you for it great news for new and
current Pure Talk customers pure talk
just added data to every plan and
includes a mobile hotspot which is
absolutely magnificent four no price
increase whatsoever if you've considered
pure talk before but haven't made the
switch take a look again for just 20
bucks a month you will get unlimited
talk text and now 50 percent more 5G
data plus their new mobile hotspot this
is one of the many reasons that I love
pure talk it's a veteran owned they only
hire the best customer service team
located right here in the great us of a
that alone makes it worth the switch
most families are saving almost a
thousand dollars a year while enjoying
the most Dependable 5G Network in
America not a similar Network the most
Dependable one remember you vote with
how you spend your money so stop
supporting woke companies that don't
support you when you go to puretalk.com
Knowles you will save an additional
fifty five zero percent off your first
month because they actually value you
puretalk.com Knowles Pure Talk Wireless
for Americans by Americans right now go
to goodranchers.com use promo code nulls
if you have not heard yet the FDA
approved lab-grown chicken for sale
there meat formed in a lab will soon be
coming to a store near you if you prefer
meat grown in a pasture instead of a
petri dish then you need good ranchers
not only do they sell real meat from
real animals but they sell the best meat
this country has to offer from
Steakhouse quality cuts of beef to
better than organic chicken everything
good Rancher sources is from local farms
in America right now you get 30 bucks
off with my code Knowles at
goodranchers.com
these guys have the best meat in the
business the burgers are the best
burgers I have ever had at home in my
entire life we had them just the other
night and then last night I went to a
steakhouse I was at a dinner a formal
dinner at a steakhouse sweet little
Elisa cooked good ranchers steak at home
I was envious of her because I was at
the steakhouse eating the steakhouse
meat I know her steak was better go it
is just the greatest go to good ranchers
right now is goodranchors.com use promo
code nulls KW Les you will use my code
Knolls get 30 bucks off any box
goodranchers.com goodrangers.com
American Meat delivered this is a bad
one
this is a bad one the FDA has approved
the first ever over-the-counter birth
control pill
the pill is called Opel it will be
available without a prescription it's a
daily oral contraceptive sold over the
counter
this is bad
this should not be permitted I won't
even say we should ban it we should just
keep the current system in place which
is that you can't get birth control over
the counter there are a lot of reasons
as to why the Liberals are thrilled
about this they want
sterility they want sterility and
promiscuous sex and everyone to be
miserable and as we follow the Liberals
sexual ethic everyone has become more
and more miserable over the last 60
years okay obviously that's what they
want the Libertarians
are probably fine with the
over-the-counter birth control thing
there are many conservatives ten years
ago who would have said oh I'm all for
that let's reduce regulations let's let
people choose to do whatever they want
the conservatives of course are going to
say no this is a bad idea and there are
a number of reasons
the really hardcore
philosophically consistent conservatives
will will name the really deep reasons
as to why this should not be permitted
first question would be what good does
it do what good can possibly come out of
over-the-counter birth control pills
well then people don't need to go get a
prescription in order to have mostly
demeaning promiscuous sex well then
people can have fewer children we have a
dying population the the birth rate in
America is below replacement and has
been for a very long time is that a good
thing to have fewer children I don't
think so is it good for individuals to
have fewer children I don't think so
it's good for society no it's not what
other good comes wrong well uh people
will have more bodily autonomy yeah
that's true I guess you have the bodily
autonomy to hack your arm off too is
that good though is that does that lead
to human flourishing no I don't think so
okay
but then
even if you're not a really hardcore
conservative even if you're a little bit
moderate you're in the middle
what else is going to come from this
well miners are going to access this
stuff
your kids your daughter is going to
access this stuff or she will have the
ability to if you say listen honey
listen 13 year old daughter I don't
think it would be good for you to have
promiscuous sex I think that would be
bad physically for you you might
contract some sexual
sexually transmitted disease you might
become pregnant not know what to do
about that
you
you might be used and abused but it
could also cause a lot of psychological
problems if starting at the age of 12 or
13 you're just used for the sexual
ratification of man without any
consequence whatsoever because they'll
have you take these pills furthermore
maybe there are some questions I know
you're not allowed to raise this
possibility but but a lot of women have
it especially in recent weeks and months
maybe it's not good to pump yourself
full of a bunch of chemicals starting at
a very young age without talking to a
doctor without talking to your family
without without really
paying a lot of consideration to this
maybe that's not a good idea to do that
sort of thing
that would be the more Centrist kind of
view of it what good comes from this do
we do we have a surplus of babies in
this country do we have do we have too
much sexual restraint in this country no
I don't think so and so the only way to
oppose this is for the conservatives to
stand up and the only way for the
conservatives to stand up is to get rid
of all this stupid nonsense about
maximizing individual autonomy that is
not freedom freedom is not just doing
whatever you want
whenever you want to do it
legalizing all the drugs legalizing all
the weird sex stuff legalizing
mutilating your body that's not Freedom
that is slavery to your bassist
appetites conservatives used to know
that we kind of went a little crazy for
a few decades there I think we're coming
back out of it now though
we need less weird sex stuff and we need
more
babies and restraint boy what a great
clip that was
now you got to ring the bell subscribe
make sure you don't miss a single clip
or episode or interview or yes or no
game or face off subscribe to the
Michael Knowles YouTube channel